either reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John hump we are
gonna watch this Hellboy featurette
called keeping it practical which I can
only assume is about the practical
makeup effects in the film now I know a
lot of you guys tend to hop ahead and
just try to go to the reaction right
away but I'd like you to stay here too I
can ask you guys a question this is we
use the feedback in the comments
basically I actually know the guy pretty
well now it's even credited on the
poster character design and special
makeup by Joel Harlow morphology wear on
your shirt buddy represent I was talking
with him about him coming by to do the
spoiler talk for Hellboy because I feel
like that'd be really cool if he joined
us for a considering that he traded the
new Hellboy he was on set the whole time
it'd be really cool to have him buy the
thing though is he's in New York until
Sunday when the Hellboy movie comes out
so we probably would be able to shoot it
so Monday and then have it up by Monday
night I know on average if you don't get
a spoiler talk up by Saturday it really
doesn't do that well or people don't
really care but I want to know if you
guys think it'd be worth a shot to do it
if you guys would want to check that
video out so feel free to leave a
comment below so that way I can try to
persuade him to come by instead he's
down I want to see if it'll actually be
worth his time man make sure he's
appreciated by the pinna yeah man I got
some things that talk to him battle to
share with you guys after the reaction
Wow
awesome violence and gore throughout yes
what I like how cool is this look looks
pretty awesome I stopped by his shop a
month and a half ago or something and he
has some of the Hellboy stuff you have
the mass but he had the bodysuit and the
glove and obviously they do something
like slight digital touch-ups we went to
see him speak at the LA makeup
convention this was like way before even
a trailer was out for the movie before
anyone could watch a cut of the movie
and I did ask him like you've worked on
so many films at this point John named
some of our on my back oh you mean like
black panther or the upcoming Jungle
Cruise or the upcoming Godzilla king of
monsters that's ready to go or Star Trek
Beyond or Pirates of the Caribbean yeah
or we're good sell the sizzle I did ask
him like what was your favorite one
you've worked on so far friends so he
doesn't have to like [ __ ] me so he
was honest and said it was the episode
of Scotty and blood works that he did oh
that's right there was a rebuff
Haussmann yeah so he said that it was
he'll Boyd that he actually was most
proud of because of the amount of
freedom he got to do to create he did
run every design any addition or
whatever if it was a made-up creature or
even just working on Hellboy they did
run it by Mike Minneola
to make sure it was as comics accurate
as possible because they didn't go
reference any of the del Toro films all
they did was work strictly he doesn't
know I'm shooting this video so if he's
pista who care who cares if this is a
terrible video he doesn't even know he
didn't like reference of all the
Guillermo del Toro films I wanted to
make sure that all the designs here were
not being influenced by the prior
installments because this is just
completely fresh and new he got to have
all this freedom to create and it's cool
because you know looking at all these
the creatures and stuff and even
stopping by his shop he'll work on
things that he's not even hired to do he
just gets inspired he found this
creature
I'm a judge drag comic book I just
started building it bringing it to life
so this is like super passionate about a
man I didn't realize he was gonna be
like pretty heavily featured in this
promo which is pretty neat yeah yeah
well and I don't know I mean as a movie
goer and as a person who's very invested
in genre films like this does actually
get me that much more excited for a
Hellboy because you know we see the
trailer and it looks like there's a ton
of potential for big CGI set pieces and
stuff but I love which they will have
definitely but it's important for the
creatures too good like though for the
fight scenes and stuff that even if
there are some digital enhancements that
you can feel the sense of realism there
yeah yeah yeah I mean getting those
close-up shots even just those behind
the scenes look at the different makeups
and the different yet creature designs
and the different ways in which they're
bringing these all to life like seeing
how the mocap figures in but then
actually seeing somebody on set doing
that spider crab walk like I I'm really
excited to see the creatures in the
effects especially in this day and age
we're like the biggest summer
blockbusters and comp remove either are
usually pretty like though though
digital things like that or like you
could have practical designed this I
feel like for film buffs especially when
you hear about practical effects usually
an instant brownie point you know oh
yeah especially if it's like a creature
of a decent you know kind of human
proportions sighs that's the kind of
stuff that we want to see come to life
as part of movie magic yeah it's like I
think back even though it's not a great
movie I think back to the troll in
Hansel and Gretel witch hunters it's
like that's a very practical element
that I feel like a lot of other films
might have CG but it really brings
something sure yeah to apply that here
I'm that much more excited excited for
how boy let me know if you want me to
try to get Joel to come by to do this
kind of wish never buy a part of the
video camera right now
I know Joel because Ashley Andrews come
on this out quite a bit as a longtime
friend of mine as Joel's our stepdad
subscribers real rejects click that
notification bell we'll catch you guys
soon keep a lookout for a Hellboy review
yada yada yada